on y va on y va on le pousse est-ce que
je peux avoir un peu d'intimité on le
pousse j'y travaille c'est pas génial
pour l'écologie mais qu'est-ce que tu
crois que je suis en train de faire de
l'hydrogène décarbonée en fait cette
hydrogène tout dépend comment on le
produisait si vous le produisez avec de
l'électricité qui elle est très carbonée
c'est-à-dire qui est faite avec du
charbon de gaz avec une électricité
décarbonée et donc nous on a une
stratégie simple on veut faire plus de
renouvelables et on était je crois l'un
des premiers pays au monde à le faire
suis ravi allez
il y va aussi du coup
[Musique]
le but c'est de les ouvrir avec un des
objets présents
même pas eu le temps de jouer
attention Anisha blague le pluriel de
Julien c'est Julie 2
une autre une autre attendez je reçois
un coup de fil là mais ça me fait jamais
mal écoute
la peinture
voilà voilà comme dirait Barbara pravi
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir OK
est-ce que c'est une blague que vous me
faites
comment tu t'appelles Jean-Maxime
non mais
on est d'accord qu'on se connaît pas
malheureusement non